what do you think psychedelics do to the
human mind it seems they take
the human mind to some interesting
places
is that just a little uh hack
a visual hack
or is there some profound expansion of
the mind
so let's see i i don't believe in magic
i believe in that i believe in uh
in science in
in causality um
still let's say and then as i said like
i think that the brain
that the our subjective experience of
reality is uh
we live in the simulation run by our
brain and the simulation that our brain
runs they can be very pleasant or very
hellish
drugs they are changing some hyper
parameters of the simulation it is
possible thanks to change of these hyper
parameters to actually look back on your
experience and even see that the given
things that we took for granted they are
changeable
so they allow to have a
amazing perspective there is also for
instance the fact that after dmt people
can see the
full movie inside of their head
gives me further belief
that the brain can generate the full
movie that the brain is actually
learning the model of reality to such
extent that it tries to predict what's
going to happen next yeah very high
resolution so you can replay realities
actually extremely high resolution
and it's also kind of interesting to me
that somehow there seems to be some
similarity between
these
drugs and meditation itself and i
actually started even these days to
think about meditation as a psychedelic
um do you practice meditation
i i practice meditation i mean i once
few times on the retreats and it feels
after like after second or third day of
meditation
there is a there is almost like a sense
of you know tripping
what does the meditation retreat entail
so
i mean you you wake up early in the
morning and you meditate for extended
period of time and alone
yeah so it's optimized even though there
are other people it's optimized for
isolation so you don't speak with anyone
you don't actually look into other
people's eyes
and
you know you sit on the chair and
say the passana meditation tells you uh
to focus on the breath so you try to put
all the all attention into breathing and
breathing in and breathing out and the
crazy thing is that as you focus
attention like that
after some time
their stamps starts coming back like
some
memories that you completely forgotten
it almost feels like um that you have a
mailbox and then you
you know you are just like a archiving
email one by one
and at some point at some point there is
like a
amazing feeling
of getting to mailbox zero
zero emails and uh it's very pleasant
it's it's kind of it's it's
it's
crazy to me
that
that once
you resolve these
inner stories or like inner traumas
then once there is nothing
uh left
that default state of human mind is
extremely peaceful and happy extreme
like some sense it it feels that the
it feels
at least to me that way how when i was a
child that i can look at any object and
it's very beautiful i have a lot of
curiosity about the simple things and
that's where usually meditation takes me
are you
what are you experiencing are you just
taking in simple sensory
information and they're just enjoying
the rawness of that sensory information
so there's no
there's no memories or all that kind of
stuff you're just enjoying
being
yeah pretty much i mean still there is a
there it's it's thoughts are slowing
down sometimes they pop up but it's also
somehow the extended meditation takes
you to the space that they are
way more friendly you way more positive
um there is also this uh this thing that
we've actually
it almost feels that the
it almost feels that the
we are constantly getting a little bit
of a reward function and we are just
spreading this reward function on
various activities but if you stay still
for extend period of time it kind of
accumulates accumulates accumulates
and
there is a there is a sense there is a
sense that at some point it passes some
threshold and it feels as
drop is falling into kind of ocean of
love and bliss and that's like a
this is like a very pleasant and as i'm
saying okay that corresponds to the
subjective experience
some people
uh i guess in spiritual community they
describe it that that's the reality and
i would say i believe that they're like
all sorts of subjective experience that
one can have and
i believe that for instance meditation
might take you to the subjective
experiences which are very pleasant
collaborative and i would like a word to
move the word a more collaborative
place
yeah i would say that's very pleasant
and i enjoy doing stuff like that i i
i wonder how that maps to your uh
mathematical model of love with the the
reward function combining a bunch of
things
it seems like our life
then is we're just we have this reward
function and we're accumulating a bunch
of stuff in it
with weights
it's like uh like multi-objective
and
what meditation is is you just remove
them remove them until the weight on one
uh or just a few is is very high and
that's where the pleasure comes from
yeah so it's something similar how i'm
thinking about this so i told you that
there is like a
there is a story of who you are
and i think almost about it as a you
know text prepended to gpt
yeah and
some people refer to it as ego okay it's
like a story
who who who you are okay so ego is the
prompt for gpg three gpg yes yes and
that's description of you and then with
meditation you can get to the point that
actually you experience things without
the prompt
and you experience things like as they
are you are not biased over the
description how they supposed to be
that's very pleasant and then with
respect to the reward function and it's
possible to
get to the point that
there is dissolution of self
and therefore you can say that the earth
you are having a your or like a your
brain attempts to stimulate the reward
function of everyone else or like
everything that's there is this like a
love which feels like a oneness with
everything
and that's also you know very beautiful
very pleasant at some point
you might have a lot of altruistic
thoughts during that moment and then
the self
always comes back how would you
recommend
if somebody is interested in meditation
like a big thing to take on as a project
would you recommend a meditation retreat
how many days what kind of thing would
you recommend i think that actually
retreat is the way to go and it almost
feels that
as i said like a meditation is a
psychedelic but
when you take it in the small dose you
might barely feel it once you get the
high dose actually you're gonna feel it
um
so even cold turkey if you haven't
really seriously meditated for prolonged
period of time just go to a retreat yeah
how many days how many days start the
weekend one weekend so like two three
days
and it's like it's interesting that
first or second day it's hard and at
some point it becomes easy
there's a lot of seconds in a day how
hard is the meditation retreat just
sitting there in a chair
so the thing is actually
it literally just depends on your
on death your own framing like if you
are in the mindset that you are waiting
for it to be over or you are waiting for
nirvana to happen it will be very
unpleasant and in some sense even the
difficulty it's not even in the
lack of being able to speak with others
like
you are sitting there your
legs will hurt from sitting
in terms of like the practical things do
you experience kind of discomfort like
physical discomfort of just sitting like
your your butt being numb your
legs being sore all that kind of stuff
yes you experience it and then the
they teach you to observe it
rather and it's like a the crazy thing
is
you at first might have a feeling toward
trying to escape it yeah and that
becomes very apparent that that's
extremely unpleasant and then you just
just observe it and
at some point it it just becomes uh it
just is
it's like a i remember with ilya told me
some time ago that you know he takes a
cold shower and his mindset of taking a
cold shower was to
embrace suffering yeah excellent i do
the same there's the art style yeah it's
my style
i like this
so my style is actually i also sometimes
take cold showers yeah it is purely
observing how the water goes through my
body like a purely being present not
trying to escape from there
yeah and i would say then it actually
becomes pleasant
you